الس
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استووا اعتدل
[Silence]
شك استووا
واعتدلوا
استو الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين واعلموا انما غنمتم من شيء فان لله
خمسه
وللرسول فان لله مسه وللرسول ولذي القربى
واليتامى والمساكين وابن السبيل ان
كنتم ان كنتم امنتم بالله وما انزلنا على
عبدنا يوم الفرقان يوم التقى
الجمعان والله على كل شيء
قدير اذ انتم بالعدوه الدنيا وهم بالعدوه
القصوى والركب اسفل منكم ولو تواعدتم
لاختلفتم في الميعاد ولكن ليقضي الله امرا
كان
مفعولا ليهلك من هلك عن بينه ويحيا من حي
عن
بينه وان الله لسميع عليم اذ يريكهم الله
في منا
قليلا ولو اراكهم كثيرا لفشلتم ولتنازعتم
في الامر ولكن الله سلم انه عليم بذات
الصدور واذ يريكموهم اذ التقيتم في اعينكم
قليلا ويقللكم في اعينهم ليقضي الله امرا
كان مفعولا
والى الله ترجع
الامور يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا لقيتم فئه
فاثبتوا فاثبتوا واذكروا الله كثيرا لعلكم
تفلحون الله
اكبر سمع الله الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن ال الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستق قيم صراط
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا لقيتم فئه
فاثبتوا واذكروا الله كثيرا لعلكم
تفلحون واطيعوا الله ورسوله ولا تنازعوا
فتفشلوا وتذهب ريحكم
واصبروا واصبروا ان الله مع
الصابرين ولا تكونوا كالذين خرجوا من
ديارهم
بطرا
ورئاء
الناس ولا تكونوا كال الذين خرجوا من
ديارهم بطرا
ورئاء الناس ويصدون عن سبيل
الله والله بما يعملون
محيط والله بما يعملون محيط واذ قال لهم
الشيطان واذ زين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم وقال
لا غالب لكم اليوم من الناس واني جار
لكم فلما
تراءت الفئتان نكص على عقبيه وقال اني
بريء منكم اني ارى ما لا
ترون اني ارى ما لا ترون اني اخاف الله
والله شديد
العقاب اذ يقول المنافقون والذين في
قلوبهم مرض غر
هؤلاء
دينهم ومن يتوكل على الله فان الله عزيز
حكيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم رحمه الله السلام عليكم رحمه
الله
[Silence]
الح
‏there
make something
‏open
you ان شاء الله جزك الله
[Silence]
الحمد
لله ماش
‏ja
[Silence]
الله
‏s
[Silence]
استووا استووا
اعتدلوا
استو الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولو ترى اذ يتوفى الذين كفروا
الملائكه يضربون وجوههم وادبارهم وذوقوا
عذاب الحري
ذلك بما قدمت ايديكم وان الله ليس بظلام
للعبيد كداب ال فرعون والذين من قبلهم
كفروا بايات الله فاخذهم الله
بذنوبهم ان الله قوي شديد
العقاب ذلك بان الله يك مغيرا نعمه انعمها
على قوم حتى يغيروا ما
بانفسهم وان الله سميع
عليم كدا بال فرعون والذين من قبلهم كذبوا
بايات ربهم فاهلكناهم
بذنوبهم واغرقنا ال
فرعون وكل كان
ظالمين ان شر
الدواب عند الله الذين كفروا فهم لا
يؤمنون الذين عاهدت منهم ثم ينقضون عهدهم
في كل مره وهم لا
يتقون فاما
تثقفنهم في الحرب فشرد بهم من خلفهم لعلهم
يذ ذ
كرون واما تخافن من قوم خيانه فانبذ اليهم
على
سواء ان الله لا يحب
الخائنين ولا يحسبن الذين كفروا سبقوا
انهم لا
يعجزون واعدوا لهم ما استطعتم من قوه ومن
رباط الخيل ترهبون به عدو الله
وعدوكم واخرين من دونهم لا تعلمونهم الله
يعلمهم وما تنفقوا من شيء في سبيل الله
يوفى اليكم وانتم لا
تظلمون وان جنحوا للسلم فاجنح لها وتوكل
على الله
انه هو السميع
العليم وان يريدوا خيانتك فان حسبك
الله هو الذي ايدك بنصره وبالمؤمنين
والف بين
قلوبهم لو
انفقت ما في الارض جميعا ما الفت بين
قلوبهم ولكن الله الف
بينهم انه عزيز
حكيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Silence]
امين يا ايها النبي حسبك الله ومن اتبعك
من
المؤمنين يا ايها النبي حرض المؤمنين على
القتال ان يكن منكم عشر صابرون يغلبوا
مئتين وان يكن منكم مئه يغلبوا الفا من
الذين كفروا بانهم قوم لا
يفقهون الان خفف الله عنكم وعلم ان فيكم
ضعفا فان يكن منكم مئه صابره يغلب مئتين
ان يكن منكم الف يغلبوا الفين باذن
الله والله مع
الصابرين ما كان لنبي ان يكون له اسرى حتى
يثخن في الارض تريدون عرض الدنيا والله
يريد الاخره والله عزيز
حكيم لولا كتاب من الله سبق لمسكم فيما
اخذتم عذاب عظيم فكلوا مما غنمتم حلالا
طيبا واتقوا الله ان الله غفور
رحيم يا ايها النبي قل لمن في ايديكم من
الاسرى ان يعلم الله في قلوبكم خيرا يؤتكم
خيرا من ما اخذ
منكم يؤتكم خيرا مما اخذ منكم ويغفر لكم
والله غفور
رحيم وان يريدوا خيانتك فقد خالوا الله من
قبل فامكن منهم والله عليم
حكيم ان الذين امنوا وهاجروا وجاهدوا
اموالهم وانفسهم في سبيل الله والذين اووا
ونصروا اولئك بعضهم
اولياء
بعض والذين امنوا ولم يهاجروا ما لكم من
ولايتهم من شيء حتى يهاجروا وان استنصروكم
في الدين فعليكم النصر الا على قوم بينكم
وبينهم
ميثاق والله بما تعملون بصير والذين كفروا
بعضهم
اولياء بعض الا تفعلوه تكن فتنه في الارض
وفساد
كبير والذين امنوا وهاجروا وجاهدوا في
سبيل الله والذين اووا ونصروا اولئك هم
المؤمنون حقا لهم مغفره ورزق
كريم والذين امنوا من بعد وهاجروا وجاهدوا
معكم فاولئك
منكم واولو الارحام بعضهم اولى ببعض في
كتاب
الله ان الله بكل شيء
عليم الله الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعم ت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
براءه من الله ورسوله الى الذين عاهدتم من
المشركين فسيحوا في الارض اربعه اشهر
واعلموا انكم غير غير معجز الله وان
واعلموا انكم غير معجز
الله وبشر الذين كفروا بعذاب
اليم براءه من الله ورسوله الى الذين
عاهدتم من المشركين فسيحوا في الارض اربعه
اشهر واعلموا انكم غير معجز
وان الله مخزي
الكافرين واذان من الله ورسوله الى ال
الناس يوم الحج الاكبر ان الله
بريء ان الله بريء من المشركين ورسوله فان
تبتم فهو خير لكم وان توليتم فاعلموا انكم
غير معجز الله
بشر الذين كفروا بعذاب
اليم الا الذين عاهدتم من المشركين ثم لم
ينقصوكم شيئا ولم يظاهر عليكم احدا فاتموا
اليهم عهدهم الى
مدتهم ان الله يحب
المتقين فاذا انسلخ الاشهر الحرم فاقتلوا
المشركين حيث وجدت ت موهم وخذوهم واحصروهم
وخذوهم واحصروهم واقعدوا لهم كل مرصد فان
تابوا واقاموا الصلاه واتوا الزكاه فخلوا
سبيلهم ان الله غفور
رحيم وان احد من المشركين استجارك
حتى يسمع كلام الله ثم ابلغهم مامنه ذلك
بانهم قوم لا
يعلمون كيف يكون للمشركين عهد عند الله
وعند رسوله الا الذين عاهدتم عند المسجد
الحرام فما استقاموا لكم فاستقيموا لهم ان
الله يحب
المتقين كيف وان يظهروا عليكم يرقبوا فيكم
الا ولا ذمه يرضونكم بافواههم وتابى
قلوبهم واكثرهم
فاسقون اشتروا بايات الله ثمنا قليلا
فصدوا عن سبيله انهم ساء ما كانوا
يعملون لا يرقبون في مؤمن الا ولا ذمه
واولئك هم
المعتدون فان تابوا واقاموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه فاخوانكم في الدين ونفصل الايات
لقوم
يعلمون وان نكثوا ايمانهم من بعد عهدهم
وطعنوا في دينكم فقاتلوا ائمه الكفر فق
قلوا ائمه الكفر انهم لا ايمان لهم لعلهم
ينتهون الا تقاتلون قوما نكثوا ايمانهم
وهموا باخراج الرسول وهم بوكم اول
مره
اتخشونهم فالله احق ان تخشوه ان كنتم
مؤمنين
قاتلوهم يعذبهم الله بايديكم ويخزهم
وينصركم عليهم ويشفي صدور قوم
مؤمنين ويذهب غيظ قلوبهم ويتوب الله على
من
يشاء والله عليم
حكيم ام حسبتم ان تتركوا ولما يعلم الله
الذين جاهدوا من ولم يتخذوا من دون
الله ولم يتخذوا من دون الله ولا رسوله
ولا المؤمنين
وليجه والله خبير بما
تعملون ما كان للمشركين ان يعمروا مساجد
الله شاهدين على
انفسهم بالكفر اولئك حبط اعمالهم وفي
النار هم
خالدون انما يعمر مساجد الله من امن بالله
واليوم الاخر واقام الصلاه واتى
الزكاه واقام الصلاه واتى الزكاه ولم يخشى
الا الله فعسى
اولئك ان يكونوا من المهتدين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
ال الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
اجعلتم سقايه
الحاج وعماره المسجد الحرام كمن امن بالله
واليوم الاخر وجاهد في سبيل
الله لا يستوون عند الله والله لا يهدي
القوم الظالمين
الذين امنوا وهاجروا وجاهدوا في سبيل الله
باموالهم وانفسهم اعظم درجه عند
الله واولئك هم
الفائزون يبشرهم ربهم برحمه منه ورضوان
وجنات لهم فيها نعيم
مقيم خالدين فيها ابدا ان الله عنده اجر
عظيم يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا
اباءكم واخوانكم اولياء ان استحبوا الكفر
على
الايمان ومن يتولهم منكم فاولئك هم
الظالمون قل ان كان
اباؤكم
وابناؤكم واخوان
وازواجكم
وعشيرتكم وعشيرتكم واموال اقترفتموها
وتجاره تخشون كسادها ومساكن ترضونها احب
اليكم احب اليكم من الله ورسوله وجهاد في
سبيله
فتربصوا فتربصوا حتى ياتي الله بامره
والله لا يهدي قوم
الفاسقين لقد نصركم الله في مواطن كثيره
ويوم حنين اذ اعجبتكم كثرتكم فلم تغن عنكم
شيئا وضاقت عليكم الارض بما
رحبت وضاقت عليكم الارض بما رحبت ثم وليتم
مدبرين ثم انزل الله سكينته على رسوله
وعلى المؤمنين وانزل جنودا لم ترها وعذب
الذين
كفروا وذلك جزاء
الكافرين ثم يتوب الله من بعد ذلك على من
يشاء والله غفور
رحيم يا ايها الذي امنوا انما المشركون
فلا يقرب المسجد الحرام بعد عامهم هذا
وان خفتم عيله فسوف يغنيكم الله من فضله
ان
شاء ان الله عليم
حكيم قاتلوا الذين لا يؤمنون بالله ولا
باليوم الاخر ولا يحرمون ما حرم الله
ورسوله ولا
يدينون ولا يدينون دين الحق من الذين
اوتوا الكتاب حتى يعطوا الجزيه عن يد وهم
صاغرون وقالت اليهود عزير ابن الله وقالت
النصارى المسيح ابن
الله ذلك قولهم بافواههم يضاهئون قول
الذين كفروا من قبل
قاتلهم الله انا
يؤفكون اتخذوا احبارهم ورهبانهم
اربابا من دون الله والمسيح ابن مريم وما
امروا الا ليعبدوا الها واحدا لا اله الا
هو سبحانه عما
يشركون يريدون ان يطفئ نور الله
بافواههم ويابى الله الا ان يتم نوره ولو
كره
الكافرون هو الذي ارسل رسوله بالهدى ودين
الحق ليظهره على الدين
كله ليظهره على الدين كله ولو كره
المشركون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏jag
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله وصحبه ومن ولاه ومن تبع باحسان
ال يوم الدين ا بعد
[Silence]
حث
‏us make
[Silence]
‏as
‏in
[Silence]
الله وباند
‏bring that
weif from my
personals best do
it out
[Silence]
‏all
‏i think people how
people
bl
was very
po was
[Silence]
‏was where said was here here making now
and man so you know i up and i looked
for him he said maybe you see him you
know somewhere i i can't i
can't so
before let
me it wasn't something that you know
that was you know
[Silence]
علام
‏and one right in front of me who by
j when make and that is time out the
heart so i said salam to said we walk
together i talk to him for a little bit
said in meet and that's the rest of the
story in i don't i don't want to indulge
in that story you know so we met after
the cle days
was time اند
[Silence]
‏انء اللهن
اللهه all
[Silence]
الله مال
الله ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر
وقنا عذاب جهنم وكنا شرف المحت وك شرف
المسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل منا السميع
العليم وتوب علي تواب الرحيم وصلى على
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين بحمم اللهم
امين اللهم امين اللهم امين جزك الله
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدل استو سو الصف سد
الخلل
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا ان كثيرا من
الاحبار والرهبان لياكلون اموالا الناس
بالباطل ويصدون عن سبيل
الله والذين يكنزون الذهب والفضه ولا
ينفقونها ولا ينف فونها في سبيل الله
فبشرهم بعذاب اليم يوم يحمى عليها في نار
جهنم فتكوى بها جباههم وجنوبهم
وظهورهم هذا ما كنزتم
لانفسكم فذوقوا ما كنتم
تكنزون ان عده الشهور عند الله اث عش شهرا
في كتاب
الله في كتاب الله يوم خلق السماوات
والارض منها اربعه
حرم ذلك الدين
القيم فلا تظلموا
فيهن
انفسكم وقاتلوا المشركين
كافه كما يقال ت لونكم
كافه واعلموا ان الله مع
المتقين انما
النسيء زياده في الكفر يضل به الذين
كفروا يضل به الذين كفروا يحلونه عاما
ويحرمونه عاما ليواطئوا
يحلونه عاما
ويحرمونه عاما ليواطئوا عده ما حرم الله
فيحلوا ما حرم الله زين لهم
سو
اعمالهم والله لا يهدي القوم
الكافرين والله لا يهدي القوم الكافرين
يا ايها الذين امنوا ما لكم اذا قيل لكم
انفروا في سبيل الله اثاقلتم الى الارض
ارضيتم بالحياه الدنيا من
الاخره فما متاع الحياه الدنيا في الاخره
الا
قليل الا تنفروا يعذبكم عذابا الي
ويستبدل قوما
غيركم ويستبدل قوما غيركم ولا تضروه
شيئا والله على كل شيء
قدير الا
تنصروه فقد نصره الله اذ اخرجه الذين
كفروا ثاني اثنين اذ هما في
الغار اذ وما في الغار اذ يقول لصاحبه لا
تحزن ان الله
معنا فانزل الله سكينته عليه وايده بجنود
لم
تروها وجعل كلمه الذين كفروا السفلى وكلمه
الله هي
العليا والله عزيز حكيم انفروا
خفافا وثقالا
وجاهدوا وجاهدوا باموالكم
وانفسكم في سبيل
الله ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون لو كان عرضا قريبا وسفرا قاصدا
لاتبعوك
لاتبعوك ولكن بعدت عليهم الشقه وسيحلفون
بالله لو
استطعنا لخرجنا
معكم يهلكون
انفسهم والله يعلم انهم
لكاذبون عفى الله
عنك لم اذنت لهم لم اذنت لهم حتى يتبين لك
الذين صدقوا وتعلم
الكاذبين لا يستاذنك الذين يؤمنون بالله
واليوم الاخر ان
يجاهدوا ان يجاهدوا باموالهم
وانفسهم والله عليم
بالمتقين
انما يستاذنك الذين لا يؤمنون بالله
واليوم الاخر وارتابت
قلوبهم وارتابت قلوبهم فهم في ريبهم
يترددون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين ولو ارادوا الخروج لاعدوا له عده
ولكن كره الله
بعثهم ولكن كره الله انبعاثهم فثبطهم وقيل
اقعدوا مع
القاعدين لو خرجوا فيكم ما زادوكم الا
خبالا ووضعوا خلالكم يبغونكم الفتنه وفيكم
سماعون لهم والله عليم
بالظالمين لقد ابتغوا الفتنه من قبل
وقلبوا لك الامور
حتى حتى
جاء الحق وظهر امر الله وهم
كارهون ومنهم من يقول اذ لي ولا
تفتني الا في الفتنه سقطوا وان جهنم
لمحيطه
بالكافرين وان
جهنم
لمحيطه
بالكافرين ان تصب ان تصبك حسنه تسؤهم وان
تصبك مصيبه يقولوا قد اخذنا امرنا من
قبل ويتولوا وهم
فرحون قل لن يصيبنا الا ما كتب الله لنا
هو مولانا وعلى الله
فليتوكل
المؤمنون قل هل تربصون بنا الا احدى الحسن
نين ونحن نتربص بكم ان يصيبكم الله
بعذاب من عنده او
بايدينا فتربصوا
انا معكم
متربصون قل انفقوا طوعا او كرها لن يتقبل
منكم انكم كنتم ق من
فاسقين وما منعهم ان تقبل منهم
نفقاتهم
الا الا انهم كفروا بالله وبرسوله ولا
ياتون الصلاه الا وهم
كسالا ولا ياتون الصلاه الا وهم كسالى ولا
ينفقون الا وهم
كارهون فلا تعجبك اموالهم ولا
اولادهم انما يريد الله
ليعذبهم بها في الحياه
الدنيا وتزهق
انفسهم وهم وهم
كافرون ويحلفون بالله انهم لمعكم
انهم لمنكم وما هم
منكم
ولكنهم قوم
يفرقون لو يجدون ملجا او مغارات او مدخلا
لولوا اليه وهم
يجمحون ومنهم من يلمزك في
الصدقات فان اعطوا فان عطوا منها رضوا وان
لم يعطوا منها اذا هم
يسخطون فان اعطوا منها رضوا وان لم يعطوا
منها اذا هم
يسخطون ولو انهم رضوا ما اتاهم الله من
فضله
ورسوله ولو انهم رضوا ما اتاهم الله
ورسوله من فضله
وقالوا وقالوا حسبنا الله سيؤتينا الله من
فضله
ورسوله
انا الى الله
راغبون الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏so just quick announcement
12 ح ان شاء
الله
ح استقم
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
انما الصدقات
للفقراء والمساكين
والعاملين عليها
والمؤلفه قلوبهم وفي الرقاب والغارمين
والغارمين وفي سبيل الله وابن السبيل
فريضه من
الله والله عليم حكيم ومنهم الذين يؤذون
النبي ويقولون هو اذن قل اذن خير لكم يؤمن
بالله ويؤمن للمؤمنين ورحمه للذين امنوا
منكم والذين يؤذون رسول الله لهم عذاب
اليم يحلفون بالله لكم ليرضوكم والله
ورسوله احق ان يرضوه ان كانوا
مؤمنين الم يعلموا انه من يحادد الله
ورسوله فان له نار جهنم خالدا
فيها ذلك الخزي العظيم يحذر المنافقون ان
تنزل عليهم سوره تنبئهم بما في
قلوبهم قل احذروا ان الله مخرج ما
تحذرون و ان سالتهم ليقولن انا كن انما
كنا نخوض
ونلعب قل ابله واياته ورسوله
واياته كنتم
تستهزئون قل ابله واياته ورسوله ك قل ابله
ورسول قل ابله واياته ورسوله
كنتم
تستهزئون لا تعتذروا قد كفرتم بعد
ايمانكم ان نعف عن
طائفه منكم نعذب
طائفه نعذب
طائفه
بانهم كانوا
مجرمين المنافقون
والمنافقات بعض هم من بعض
يامرون يامرون
بالمنكر وينهون عن المعروف ويقبضون
ايديهم نسوا الله فنسيهم ان المنافقين هم
الفاسقون وعد الله المنافقين
والمنافقات والكفار نار جهنم خالدين في
فيها هي حسبهم ولعنهم الله ولهم عذاب
مقيم كالذين من قبلكم كانوا اشد منكم
اموالا
واولادا
فاستمتعوا كالذين من قبلكم كانوا اشد منكم
قوه
واموالا
اولادا كالذين من قبلكم كانوا اشد منكم
قوه واكثر اموالا
واولادا فاستمتعوا بخلاقهم
فاستمتعتم بخلاقكم كما استمتع الذين من
قبلكم
بخلاقهم وخضتم كالذي خاضوا اول
اولئك حبطت اعمالهم في الدنيا
والاخره
واولئك هم
الخاسرون الم ياتهم نبا الذين من قبلهم
قوم نوح وعاد
وثمود وعاد وثمود وقوم ابراهيم واصحاب
مدين
اتتهم رسلهم بالبينات فما كان الله
ليظلمهم ولكن كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون
والمؤمنون والمؤمنات
بعضهم
اولياء بعض
يامرون يامرون بالمعروف وينهون عن المكر
ويقيمون الصلاه ويؤتون
الزكاه ويقيمون الصلاه ويؤتون الزكاه
ويطيعون الله
ورسوله
اولئك سيرحمهم
الله والله غفور
رحيم
اولئك سيرحمهم الله والله عزيز
حكيم
اولئك سيرحمهم الله ان الله عزيز حكيم وعد
الله المؤمنين والمؤمنات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها خالدين فيها ومساكن
طيبه في جنات
عدن
ورضوان من الله اكبر ذلك هو الفوز العظيم
يا ايها النبي جاهد الكفار والمنافقين
واغلظ عليهم وماواهم
جهنم وبئس
المصير يحلفون
ما قالوا ولقد قالوا كلمه الكفر وكفروا
بعد
اسلامهم وكفروا بعد اسلامهم وهموا بما لم
ينالوه وما نقموا الا ان اغناهم الله
ورسوله من فضله فان يتوبوا يك خيرا
لهم وان يتولوا يعذب م الله عذابا اليما
في الدنيا
والاخره وما لهم في الارض من
ولي ولا
نصير الله
اكبر سمع الله
لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين ومنهم من عاهد الله لئن اتانا من
فضله
لنصدقن
ولنكونن من
الصالحين فلما اتاهم من فضله بخلوا به
وتولوا وتولوا وهم معرضون
فاعقبهم نثا في قلوبهم الى يوم يلقونه بما
اخلفوا الله ما
وعدوه وبما كانوا
يكذبون الم يعلموا ان الله يعلم سرهم
ونجواهم وان الله علام
الغيوب الذين يلمزون المطوعين من المؤمنين
في الصدقات والذين لا يجدون الا
جهدهم والذين لا يجدون الا جهدهم فيسخرون
منهم سخر الله منهم سخر الله منهم ولهم
عذاب اليم استغفر لهم او لا تستغفر لهم ان
تستغفر لهم سبعين مره
ان تستغفر لهم سبعين مره فلن يغفر الله
لهم ذلك بانهم كفروا بالله
وبرسوله والله لا يهدي القوم
الفاسقين فرح
المخلفون فرح
المخلفون فرح المخلفون خلاف رسول الله
وكرهوا
يجاهدوا باموالهم
وانفسهم في سبيل الله
وقالوا وقالوا لا
تنفروا في الحر
قل فرح المخلفون بمقعدهم خلاف رسول الله
وكرهوا ان يجاهدوا باموالهم
وانفسهم في سبيل الله وقالوا لا
تنفروا في الحر قل نار جهنم اشد حرا لو
كانوا
يفقهون فليضحكوا
قليلا وليبكوا
كثيرا
جزاء بما كانوا
يكسبون فان رجعك الله الى
طائفه منهم فاستاذنتها
فاستاذنتها
انكم رضيتم بالقعود اول مره فاقعدوا مع
الخالفين
ولا تصل على احد منهم مات ابدا ولا تقم
على قبره انهم كفروا بالله
وبرسوله وماتوا وهم
فاسقون ولا تعجبك اموالهم
واولادهم
انما يريد الله ان
يعذبهم بها في الحياه في الدنيا وتزهق
انفسهم وهم
كافرون واذا انزلت سوره ان امنوا بالله
وجاهدوا مع
رسوله استاذنك اول الطول منهم وقالوا ذرنا
نكن مع
القاعدين رضوا بان يكونوا مع الخوالف وطبع
على قلوبهم فهم لا
يعلمون وطبع على قلوب بهم فهم لا
يفقهون لكن الرسول والذين امنوا معه
جاهدوا باموالهم
وانفسهم
واولئك لهم الخيرات
واولئك هم
المفلحون اعد الله لهم
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها ذلك الفوز
العظيم وجاء المعذرون من الاعراب ليؤذن
لهم وقعد الذين كذبوا الله
ورسوله سيصيب الذين كفروا منهم
عذاب
اليم الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم واعتد
ست
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهد ا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين لايلاف
قريش ايلافهم رحله
الشتاء والصيف
فليعبدوا رب هذا
البيت الذي
اطعمهم من جوع
وامنهم من
خوف
الله سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غغير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما
عبدتم ولا انتم
دون ما
اعبد لكم دينكم ولي
دين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله
لمن حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد في
الاولين وصل على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين
وصل على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت وحين اللهم
صل على سيدنا محمد حتى ترث الارض ومن
عليها وانت خير
الوارثين اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا ويا
سيدنا ويا
الهنا يا من تسمع كلامنا وترى مكاننا
وتعلم سرنا
وعلانيتنا يا من لا يخفى عليك شيء من
امرنا نستغفرك ربنا من جميع الذنوب
والخطايا ونتوب اليك نستغفرك ربنا من جميع
الذنوب
والخطايا ونتوب اليك اللهم تقبل منا
صيامنا اللهم تقبل منا
صيامنا
وصلاتنا
وقيامنا وقراننا وصالح
اعمالنا اللهم تقبلها لوجهك الكريم خالصه
لوجهك الكريم اللهم يا يا ربنا ويا مولانا
ويا سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن والعطاء يا ذا
الجلال
والاكرام يا حي يا
قيوم يا بديع السماوات والارض ويا رحمن
الدنيا والاخره
ورحيمهما اللهم لا تدع لنا ذنبا الا غفرته
ولا هما الا نفسته ولا كربا الا سهلته ولا
دينا الا قضيته ولا دينا الا قضيته ولا
حالا الا اصلحته ولا ولدا الا اصلحته ولا
مريضا الا شفيته ولا مبتلا الا
عافيته ولا
ضالا الا هديته ولا ميتا من اموات
المسلمين الا رحمته اللهم اصلح لنا شاننا
اللهم اصلح لنا ديننا الذي هو عصمه امرنا
واصلح لنا دنيانا التي فيها
معاشنا واجعل اللهم الحياه الدنيا زياده
لنا في كل خير والموت راحه لنا من كل شر
اللهم
واجرنا من خزي الدنيا وعذاب
بالاخره اللهم ارحم والدينا كما ربونا
صغارا اللهم ارحمهم واللهم جازم بالاحسان
احسانا وبالسيئات عفوا
وغفرانا اللهم تجاوز عنا
السيئات وتحمل عنا
التبعات برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم كل
للمستضعفين من المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم
احرسهم بحراسته اللهم ا كلاهم بكك اللهم
ابن عليهم سور حمايتك اللهم اجعلهم في
رعايتك اللهم ادفع عنهم
ودافع سبحان ربك رب العزه عما
يصفون وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏jetzt